We have gone over the decision from the Supreme
Court from yesterday, which said you can't shield
your tax returns from Manhattan prosecutors
anymore. Donald Trump. That's the decision
made by the Supreme Court. The documents with
reportedly almost no delay will be turned over to
Manhattan District Attorney Cyrus Vance and will
be made part of the grand jury that Cyrus Vance
is running. OK, Donald Trump exploded at news
of this, putting out a statement on the, quote,
continuing political persecution of President
Donald Trump. This is a very funny letter in
which Donald Trump alternates between referring to
himself in the first person and the third person.
It's riddled with lots of other wacky things. And
I want to go through it with you because it is
actually incredible that this is a letter from
a former president of the United States. It's
almost like a third grader wrote a joke letter.
Let's get right into it. Quote, This investigation
is a continuation of the greatest political witch
hunt. Witch hunt capitalized. We'd never know
why in the history of our country whether it was
the never ending 32 million dollar Muehler hoax,
which, remember, recovered far more than the
32 million that it cost, Trump goes on to say,
which already investigated everything that could
possibly be investigated Russia, Russia, Russia,
where there was a finding of no collusion. That's,
of course, untrue or too ridiculous. Crazy. Nancy
inspired impeachment attempts where I was found
not guilty. It never ends. So now, for more than
two years, New York City has been looking
at almost every transaction I've ever done,
including seeking tax returns, which were done
by among the biggest and most prestigious law
and accounting firms in the United States. Now,
remember, when you have someone do your taxes,
you are always signing off and saying you are
warranting that the information you give to
them is true. They are merely completing the taxes
based on what you tell them. So the idea that the
prestige of the accounting firm, when I go in,
I tell our accountant, here's how much we made.
Here's how much we spent. The accountant has
me sign something where I where I am saying
it is my responsibility. If this information
is untrue, if I'm lying about the value of a
building or whatever that's on me, that's not on
the account. The prestige of the accounting firm
seems irrelevant. OK, continuing the Tea Party
was treated far better by the IRS than Donald
Trump. The Supreme Court never should have let
this fishing expedition happen, but they did.
Now, what's funny is Trump puts fishing expedition
in quotes that suggests it's Trump who's skeptical
that it was actually a fishing expedition. Trump
doesn't seem to understand what quotes mean
going on to say this is something which has
never happened to a president before. It is all a
Democrat inspired in a totally Democrat location.
New York City and state completely controlled and
dominated by a heavily reported enemy of mine,
Governor Andrew Cuomo. Now, if Trump has any
evidence that Cuomo is involved in any of this,
he should release it. There is no evidence I've
seen so far. Trump continues. These are attacks
by Democrats willing to do anything to stop
the almost 75 million people, the most votes by
far ever gotten by a sitting president who voted
for me in the election, an election which many
people and experts feel that I won. I agree. So
Trump still can't get away from the it was stolen
stuff that incited the riot in the first place.
The new phenomenon of headhunting prosecutors and
AGs who try to take down their political opponents
using the law as a weapon is a threat to the very
foundation of our liberty. That's what is done in
Third World countries. Even worse are those who
run for prosecutorial or attorney general offices
and far left states and jurisdictions pledging
to take out a political opponent. That's fascism,
not justice. Funny that Trump talks about third
world countries and fascism. Trump's presidency
and his authoritarianism was more reminiscent of
that than anything we're seeing right now. Trump
goes on to say, and that is exactly what
they are trying to do with respect to me,
except that the people of our country won't
stand for it. In the meantime, murders and
violent crime are up in New York City by record
numbers and nothing is done about it. Yeah, mostly
under Trump's presidency, our elected officials
don't care. All they focus on is the persecution
of President Donald Trump. I will fight on just
as I have for the last five years, even before I
was successfully elected, despite all of the
election crimes that were committed against
me when. We will win, and it's unclear what
exactly Trump believes he is going to win. To me,
this is the rantings of a highly triggered, but
in particular very scared individual. Remember,
there are political consequences to some degree
of a presidential candidate not releasing their
tax returns. Trump knew that and he still decided
releasing them is worse for me than keeping them
private, keeping them secret and being criticized
for it. That means Trump knows the content of the
tax returns is not good for him, and that's why
he's acting in this way. What do you think is in
the tax returns? I've explained my thoughts
many times before and at this point, do you
think it even matters? Will have more coverage
of this on our Instagram page, David Pakman show.
And if you want to see the level of anti
VAX emails that we are now getting, check
my personal Instagram David Pakman where I posted
a really extreme anti VAX email that I received
this morning. Quick break. Much more coming up.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.